i lost all of my self-worth during the
[ __ ] lockdown
you know suddenly going you know i've
had i've had a very very good career
um but especially in the past two years
has been
immensely and yeah intense man netflix
came out you go
from playing 400 state rooms to 3 000
rooms and
it's an 18-month tour that takes you
know 300 shows and
you know it's all very very exciting and
and for the past
10 years all of my confidence all of my
self-worth all of who i am
i have gotten from the love and approval
of strangers
and it's been brilliant for the past 10
years it's been absolutely brilliant
it's a very strong scaffolding
to really life upon for as long as it's
still there for as long as it's still
there so
if you imagine my life as a my
personality and who i am
what i desperately tried to do was to
try and prop the [ __ ] tower back up
what did you prop it up with uh just
i mean for the first two months uh it
was back because
because i'd been so desperate for time
off for so long i saw you
i think two days after you got back we
went for
lunch in edinburgh yeah and that was
like the middle of march it was two days
before
lockdown came in um sorry before
americans weren't allowed to go back to
america and i remember because the chick
that i was with in edinburgh
had left me at 4am yes and i'm like is
this actually just all the big no no no
no no i'm sure
i'm sure that that was what the truth
was yeah and so i'd seen you and you
were like
like this is lovely but still even then
only two days after you'd finished
in the back of your head you had this
australia tour and the book which we're
going to get into
um and even then you were already kind
of putting yourself
into that well because i've always got
that so like i've whenever i've had time
off
it's always been like i've got this next
month off and i know after that i'm on
tour for another six
weeks someone two for another six months
so it's i was really good at cramming my
time off like i would be like right over
the next month i'm doing [ __ ] all
i'm sitting in a bean bag i'm playing
xbox all day and i'm smoking weed
every second of the video of my
existence because i've learned this i'll
work for those months
this is my time off i've got this job
coming up then
and whereas this didn't feel like time
off this felt like [ __ ]
unemployment like it fell
like just suddenly like in a time when
like
the people were throwing words around
key workers and like crucial workers and
you're like
[ __ ] i'm so pointless to the world
there's no
like how pointless work is that like
again and it says it's comedians it's
the last one you go [ __ ] we're dead
we're not needed right now
and there's and yeah and i was just i
couldn't
i couldn't handle the time off because
it just
it just had a nagging voice in the back
of my head going this isn't time off
you're not doing anything like
this isn't you know there isn't a tour
in two months that you're gonna get
money from there isn't a [ __ ]
you know uh a show that you need to be
working on because there's no audience
and uh it took me a while to sort of
realize what was going on because i was
just
mad eh smoking weed living my life
bothering my poor girlfriend
just like [ __ ] tapping her on the
shoulder being like hey fill the [ __ ]
void
i need you to love me as much as 2000
strangers do on a regular basis
you're busy sorry i'll go and uh
so but by the way also like kind of glad
it happened because
i had to i had to really look long and
hard in the [ __ ] mirror
because i've been i've been daniel
sloths for
it's intensely for like the past 18
months and then i was just
daniel dan aye and how the [ __ ] down
yeah i've not met him since he was a 17
year old who was just [ __ ]
you know insecure in high school who was
starting to do stand-up as a hobby and
there was only like the slight hopes in
the back of his head that he might be
able to make money out of it
one day and uh [ __ ] he doesn't have any
hobbies
[Laughter]
i didn't have because my life was so
intensely stand up all the time like i
didn't need
hobbies i wasn't even writing going out
to do things to find material for the
next show because the next show wasn't
going to happen at any point soon yeah
and normally i just gotta go to the next
city i get to meet people like drink i
do drugs i [ __ ] party i live the life
and that's you know
and then suddenly i'm just in my house
just going [ __ ]
what do i do i don't have any interests
like i don't have my only hobby was
marijuana
but what was really nice i did start
discovering like uh
not parts of myself that i'd sort of
suppress but it's part of myself
that i don't know when i was a teenager
i wasn't confident
enough to to enjoy them but like [ __ ]
d
d man you really oh god online or
mad oliver i'm the bit i love nerd [ __ ]
the the flavor was today i spent the
[ __ ]
games uh like a board game shop just
[ __ ] reading nerd books surrounded by
notes and i was like this is where i
belong
i'm with my people with my [ __ ]
people people that i deny
these mouth breathing neck bearded in
cells over here yeah
but i because i've been no man there's
past
they're so you know so i just ended up
talking to the owner of the place just
about
uh comic books and stuff for a bit so i
got to do
i don't know i got to get to start dming
sessions i am a dungeon master
so i got to do okay with a bunch of
friends all right yeah yeah and presume
zoom through zoom yes and uh man a lot
a lot of fun and like uh just i like
just
doing like archaeology on the old me and
being like i wonder if this still fits
my personality
is this thing i enjoyed when i was 17
still fit in there
apparently it is some of it's still
there and it's my it's been good
thanks to i mean thanks to [ __ ]
therapy and meditation and whatnot it's
been a lot easier now i'm
infinitely happy with it i'm glad we
didn't do this anyway four months ago
yeah were you crying weeping mess in the
corner
do you think that if it wasn't for the
fact that you're talented and have been
blessed with some like
semi-okay good looks that you would
really really struggle in life
because dungeons and dragons the wii
like you have the makings of a really
like successful incel
but you've managed to like get past that
oh i think i would have
man had i not discovered comedy i would
have i would have absolutely been a
[ __ ]
uh right wing internet [ __ ] troll
from the bottom i truly [ __ ] had not
discovered comedy i would have been one
of the
i would have been a [ __ ] proud boy
man you've been giving me gifts
yeah man if i [ __ ] if i hadn't
like got into comedy like him
and had this world where i just got to
meet so many different people from so
many
you know different backgrounds and get
to travel the world and experience
things uh i would have absolutely
been one of them you know you know it's
hard being a white man like
that would have been me because i would
have had nothing else to put it into i
would have just been
because i was quite an angry teenager
and then i mean i've still got some
anger within me
we all do but you know i got to i got to
put that anger into stand up i could
have put it into the performance all the
all this stuff i had there was an outlet
for it and thank god because if it
hadn't been it would have just been
i would have shot up a school man it's
um
it's interesting that people who don't
have that outlet and don't find
something in life i think struggle
with like their internal monologue and
one of the
interesting comments douglas murray made
on a show that i did with him recently
was he's adamant that the people who
have the most
extreme views on the left and the right
have never traveled
so it's because as soon as you travel
and you start to meet people from
different cultures
you realize like they're actually really
fun i want to know
like a japanese person like they're
[ __ ] sick and like yeah chinese
government
probably needs a bit of work but like
you meet some people from china
from china and you're like [ __ ] like
this is awesome and you're i mean
oh this when you get to travel you see
the humanity that is so common across
the world you go here's all these people
that are you know they're so different
to who i am
and then you just see a mom yelling at a
child and you go oh that's how my mom
yelled at me
oh we're all the same we are literally
we're all the same [ __ ] species we
were just born in different parts
and yeah i think it's i i think it's
such a
such important thing to travel but it's
such an unfortunate thing but it's you
know
it's something that you have to have
money to do
imagine imagine if you'd not had this
kind of like weird sabbatical break
from doing your comedy and perhaps you
further layered more and more and more
and more
life and ego have you considered this
the fact that
the the um stool's been turned upside
down a little bit and you're balancing
it on one leg
and then start you know do you remember
tom and jerry dude and when
they'd like the fridge would be balanced
on top of a fork upside down on the
floor and then
yeah yeah yeah and that's kind of what
would have happened had it have been
40 year old daniel 50 year old daniel
like coming at the end of his career and
then being like
17 year old daniel's still in here by
the way [ __ ] all right well the
eagle would have become
i mean catastrophic yes and and
and i say that as somebody whose ego two
years ago would have been described by
some of my friends his
catastrophe you know a lot of the
elegant things
uh i used to say and still sometimes say
like a lot of the time i go oh my
my tongue is firmly in my cheek and upon
further reflection now
it [ __ ] wasn't i was just uh it was
this sort of disguise of hey
if i if i if i acknowledge how arrogant
i am
that i'm going to try and pass that off
as self-awareness and irony
because even last year i remember part
of the show that you were doing that you
were touring on quite heavily was
breaking the fourth wall about this way
that you are with yourself like my
charisma is built around
this thing so it's you are right it's a
level of self-awareness but it's also
only like about that thick it's a veneer
that allows you to
make a proxy yeah for like
self-awareness but you're right without
doing the real work it's like when
people do ironic racism you go
hi but you even though you're doing it
ironically you still want to say those
things
like that's not you don't maybe say them
with malice or hatred or whatever but
there's still a deep
it comes from an extreme and and fearful
[ __ ] place
it's the same as the the people who are
the most
vehemently anti-gay they're the ones who
are the most aroused when you put them
in an mri
and work play gay pawn in front of them
who can't switch off the arousal because
like the lady doth protest too much all
right thanks for keeping
you